hello in this video we'll talk about
mechanism of gastric hcl secretion
so when the food reaches the stomach
gastric
hcl is secreted
in the stomach and this gastric hcl
help to create an acidic environment in
which
protein digestion can take place and it
also creates a optimal environment for
the enzyme pepsin
other than that gastric hcl can
also neutralize microorganisms that
are swallowed from the food so thus they
are preventing
other microorganism to enter the
intestine and create disease
so gastric hcl is very important from a
point of view
from a physiological point of view so
let's talk about
how gastric hcl is at all secreted
by the stomach so
if we zoom into the stomach there would
be
several type of cells okay so
these cells are neck cells
parietal cells and peptic cells
each of these cell type have their own
function
for example the major function of peptic
cells
is to secrete pepsinogen
by the way peptic cells are also known
as sheep cells or main cells
now the key role of neck cell is to
secrete
mucus now in contrast to all of these
cell types
parietal cell actually secretes
the hydrochloric acid and along with
hydrochloric acid
they secrete castles intrinsic factor
which in
which plays an important role in vitamin
reabsorption
so now let us focus more on parietal
cell
because parietal cell secretes the
gastric hcl and we would learn about the
mechanism
by which this parietal cell can secrete
gastric hcl when parietal cell is
stimulated in presence of food
then it can secrete hcl which contains
almost 160 millimole per liter
of hydrochloric acid that's a lot
now the ph of the acid is about 0.8
that means it's extremely acidic
and lastly parietal cell contains large
branching or
intracellular canal equally so look at
the morphology
their morphology is very different by
having these kind of
branched canal equally like structure
the surface area of secretion
has increased greatly which
improves the hcl secretion capability
now let us zoom at these one portion of
these parietal cell
to understand how hcl is generated
and secreted into the lumen so let us
zoom into this location
and try to understand what are the
molecular mechanism for hcl generation
so gastric hcl can be broken down into
two components the proton and the
chloride ion
so let us see how proton and chloride
ion are secreted
into the lumen so
the key component for production of hcl
is a hydrogen potassium pump it's a
atpase
now these hydrogen potassium pump lead
to
pumping of potassium inside the cell and
lead to extrusion
of protons and this proton is
used for hcl generation but where does
this proton come from
this proton come from splitting of water
inside the parietal cell
now there could be co2 which is coming
from the
blood capillaries or the extracellular
fluid
now co2 in combination with oh minus
ion can lead to bicarbonate ion
now bicarbonate ion
can be uh co-transported
with the with chloride ions so chloride
ions enter the parietal cell
and bicarbonate ion moves out of the
parietal cell
now this chloride ion can also be
secreted with the help of chloride
channels
with co-transporter mediated transport
and ion channel mediated transport
chloride can be secreted into the
lumen of the stomach and ultimately with
h plus and cl minus there would be
generation of gastric
hcl lastly it is important to note that
for sodium potassium balance for
maintaining the sodium potassium balance
in the cell
there are sodium potassium atps as well
and for potassium flow there are some
voltage-gated potassium channel
present in this um parietal cell as well
and here the hcl is mainly generated
with the help
of the hydrogen potassium
pump and the chloride channels and
chloride transporter so these are the
key factors
now let me tell you some basic facts
about stimulation of gastric hcl
secretion
so gastric hcl secretion is greatly
stimulated
by acetylcholine coming from the entire
nervous system
so the entire nervous system ends up on
this stomach
and in the and they secrete
acetylcholine as the neurotransmitter
stomach has lot of acetylcholine
receptor
which helps in ultimately
gastric hcl secretion other than
neuronal input hormonal inputs such as
gastrin and chemokine input such as
histamine can also lead to
lot of hcl production in the stomach
positively regulate
now acetylcholine is released by the
parasympathetic stimulation
whereas gastrin and histamine can
strongly stimulate
the hcl secretion now gastric
gastrin and about histamine we have a
different video
so let's move on and try to understand
what are the
factors that negatively stimulate
gastric secretion
factors like gip vip secretin
glucagon intraogastrone all of these
hormones actually negatively regulate
gastric hcl secretion so now in this
video we learned about both
positive and the negative regulators of
gastric
hcl secretion now
there are several phases of this gastric
secretion where hcl is secreted
and the amount of hcl secrete is
secreted is also different
there could be cephalic phase where just
looking at the food or thinking about
the food
there could be some minute hcl secretion
in the stomach
somewhere there is gastric phase
where there is local nervous system
mediated reflexes and as well as gastrin
and histamine mediated
stimulation this is the major phase
where a
huge amount of hcl is produced and
secreted
also in the intestinal phase some amount
of nervous and hormonal stimulation
together help to secrete some amount of
gastric hcl not the major part the major
secretion happens in the gastric phase
so just to summarize what we have
learned in this video we have learned
the cell types in the stomach
and which cell type secretes hcl we
learned it to be parietal cell
we learn the characteristic morphology
of parietal cell and the molecular
mechanism by which parietal cell
secretes gastric hcl lastly we looked at
the
positive and the negative regulator of
gastric hcl secretion
and that kind of summarized this video
so i hope you liked this video and this
content was very informative for you
if you like this video give it a quick
thumbs up don't forget to like share and
subscribe
and please please please comment in the
video such that i know
how you are liking my videos your
comment is my motivation
and lastly my courses are also present
in an academy which is india's
biggest learning platform if you want to
access my
courses you can use my code mp10 to get
a 10 discount
on my courses thank you guys see you
next time in the next video